gorbatchev qui nous a accordé accordée à
france 2 un entretien enregistré la
semaine dernière première question à
celui qui initia la pérestroïka cette
date de 1989 cette chute du mur de
berlin sont-elles symbolique à vos yeux
vous savez la chute du mur de berlin
n'est pas l'événement le plus important
c'est un symbole de l'époque et de tout
ce qui s'est passé alors certes on
pourrait dire de 89 a été une année
charnière
[Musique]
en union soviétique ont eu lieu des
élections libres les premières en mille
ans d'histoire de la russie le parlement
a commencé à fonctionner des partis
politiques se sont créés c'était le
début du pluralisme
et gelées ne pas souhaité dire la barre
et tenir en europe centrale et orientale
il ya eu des révolutions de velours
à la fois reflets et prolongement de la
pérestroïka laisser événement était en
préparation depuis quatre ou cinq ans il
c'était un aboutissement logique
pensé à ce moment là en novembre 89 que
c'était définitivement la fin du système
soviétique et la fin de l'urss très
gourdins
pendant trois ans j'ai essayé
d'améliorer le système de socialisme
réel comme nous l'appelions y compris
que ce système n'était pas réformable
qu'il fallait le transformer sortir du
système totalitaire et se lancer sur la
voie de la démocratie et du pluralisme
de ce fait tout cela n'avait rien
d'inattendu pour moi les processus qui
se sont déroulés en union soviétique ont
bien sûr eu un impact sur les pays
d'europe de l'est et d'europe centrale
concernant la réunification de
l'allemagne est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment maintenant dix ans après qu
aussi bien
vous-même que le président bush que le
chancelier kohl août le président
mitterrand vous avait sous-estimé cette
envie des allemands d'être sûrs réuni
votre manette badini berlin au moment de
la chute du mur de berlin nous ne
pensions pas que la réunification aurait
lieu tout de suite dany prêt social
même cole lors de nos discussions disait
que la réunification serait pour le 21e
siècle
quel serait la sphère des générations
suivantes
au bout de chaque année nous partageons
tous cette opinion facebook de savions
que le processus aurait lieu mais qu'il
serait lent
nous en avons discuté avec le président
mitterrand margaret thatcher bush
andreotti nous étions tous d'avis qu'il
ne fallait pas se hâter y aller
progressivement et que la réunification
devrait se faire en synchronisation avec
le processus européen
en russie beaucoup sont nostalgiques de
l'ancien régime et ils vous disent oui
vous nous avez donné la liberté mais
nous n'avons plus de quoi manger et il
n'estime que mikhaïl gorbatchev les a
trahis d'une certaine manière qu'est ce
que vous pouvez leur répondre
ils disent vrai ils ont reçu la liberté
ils en ont fait ce qu'ils voulaient
le résultat a été l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique au moment du
démantèlement le peuple n'a pas exprimé
son désaccord et pourtant les occasions
n'ont pas manqué ils ont suivi cette
voie là et appliquer la thérapie de choc
redistribuer les biens publics l'ourson
et entre temps les criminels ont plongé
leurs mains dans cette fange
vous visez boris elstine et sa famille
quand vous dites ceux qui ont mis leur
argent à droite à gauche et est ce que
la famille yassine ne devra passer
devant la justice l'individu je ne crois
pas que le président soit à vau l'eau
peut-être est-ce moi qui suis comme cela
mais je n'imagine pas qu'un président
puisse faire une chose pareille ce
serait la fin de tout comment vivre
après cela
à l'occasion de du décès de votre épouse
il ya une très forte émotion dans le
monde entier et y compris en russie est
ce que vous n'avez pas eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait une reconnaissance tardive
de l'action qui a été menée par votre
épouse et de ce que vous représentez
je disais à mon épouse les articles les
lettres certaines seulement car nous en
recevions des milliers en russie ou à
l'hôpital où elle était soignée à
munster en allemagne
je pensais qu'il fallait qu'elle le
sache bien qu'elle fût très malade et
elle voulait les entendre
elle pleurait se demandait pourquoi il
fallait qu'elle fume ou rendent pour que
les gens là comprennent et lui expriment
leurs amis
mais c'est comme ça comment dire ce
n'est pas nouveau nous chérissons jamais
assez ce que nous avons il n'y est après
lorsque nous l'avons perdue nous
pleurons et nous regrettons tout
cela est vrai pour tous les peuples pas
seulement pour les russes cependant qui
c'est arrivé elle vivait encore elle l'a
su et c'était important
il y en a toujours
[Musique]